Alors évidement
Bonjour à tous
Aujourd'hui je suis avec Pierre Croce
et je suis chez Pierre Croce
et dans la chambre de mon coloc'
dans la chambre du coloc'
Je me suis dit on ne mentalise pas Pierre Croce comme ça tu vois
non
Par contre toi peut-être que t'es un mentaliste et que tu le sais pas encore
Je suis un mentaliste
C'est vrai ?
Pourquoi t'ouvres pas une deuxième chaine de mentalisme
Je suis sur le projet d'une deuxième chaîne
La mental Croce
Mais avec deux S
Tous les jours des vidéos de deux heures de mentalisme
Est-ce que je peux prendre un des livres de ton colocataire, c'est possible ou pas ?
Ouais, je sais pas ce qu'il lit. Oh, Peut-être que c'est nul
Peut-être que c'est la biographie de Jean Edin ?
Passionnant
Ok, le but du jeux pour moi, ça va pas être de deviner quelque chose que tu penses mais de t'envoyer une pensée et que toi tu la trouves
Comme un SMS
Comme... Exactement
Tu veux pas passer par le téléphone, c'est plus simple
Ouai c'est vrai
On arrête le... Ça s’arrête là. C'est deux minutes la vidéo et c'est bon
Je vais choisir quelque chose d'assez simple, pas quelque chose de trop compliqué
"le"
ah ah ah ah
Je suis impatient
Ça c'est pas mal
T'as un peu d'imagination ? Ça va ? Tu visualises les choses facilement ? Ou pas ?
Ouais, je suis très visuel
ah cool
ouais
Alors ça ça m’arrange dans ce cas là tu vas imaginer devant toi un grand paperboard
Je vais t'envoyer mentalement un mot assez simple, quelque chose d'assez simple, qu'on peut dessiner assez facilement ok
Donc t'es entrain de le dessiner là dans ta tête
La je dessine un zizi
d'accord, quelque chose d'assez classique ou pas
ouais, classique vraiment, la base
ok, est-ce que maintenant tu peux efface le dessin
ouais
ou le rayer
attend, il me faut juste un chiffon
tiens
ok, ouais
c'est bon
et tu l'écris en toutes lettres maintenant a la place
ouais bien sur
su tu avais mis un bureau à la place, tu écris bureau
C'est bon, c'est écrit en toutes lettres
Je vous fais bien voir quand même où est mon doigt, pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'embrouilles.
Est-ce que tu peux nous dire la troisième lettre
un i
i
ouais
Vas-y continu tout haut
S. O. N.
"Maison"
Regarde, juste je te fais voir avec mon doigt
sur quoi j'étais
J'étais bien sur "maison"
ouf, là je me suis auto-bluffé
Je suis vraiment bluffé
"chuchotements"
C'est très fort, mais Fabien Olicard c'est très fort
ah ah ah ah
Merci beaucoup
Merci à toi
Merci
Merci Fabien, on fait des checks de mentalistes
Et bien n'hésitez pas surtout à vous abonnez à la chaîne de Fabien Olicard et puis aussi à la mienne
et oui
Si je peux un peu vampiriser tes abonnés
Je peux te dire que là
Merci beaucoup, rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog, Ciao